I do think there is such a thing as too
much anticipation so this is one of
those videos that I just had a thought
that I think I can get a video out of
that and I kind of want to talk it
through so I'm going to talk about cuz I
mentioned this when I talked about the
Captain Marvel first trailer coming out
that the marketing cycle for the major
blockbusters appears to have shrunk back
down to about a six month cycle from
when we get the first real tangible
piece of marketing usually an official
image followed by a trailer which you
know Captain Marvel that's that's coming
out early in 2019 it's about six months
out from when the trailer dropped and
that is frankly a monumental relief for
me because we had a period of a few
years where the big blockbusters got on
to a kick of giving us a teaser and
start dropping trailer material a year
out from release and I think that
actively damaged the release of some
films some notable ones even and I kind
of want to just talk through the history
how that happened and why it was a bad
thing and why I'm really glad it seems
to be a phase that was relatively
short-lived I think in many ways the
whole thing kicked off with Star Wars
The Force awakens
because in 2014 at the very end of 2014
we got the first teaser for a brand new
Star Wars movie and it was really really
really good I I will still stand by that
teaser it gave me chills down my spine
you know the Luke's voice you have that
power to like still gives me chills I I
think it was a fantastically composed
trailer and Star Wars especially knowing
how long it
been since the last film had been in the
theaters and you know the potential of
what these new films could be it was the
kind of property that you could get away
with dropping a first teaser that far
out but that was also really carefully
put together teaser in terms of showing
things that were complete and really
only having a couple of notable special
effect shots in it
you know it's it's a lot of black it's a
lot of voiceover it's you know it's Finn
in the desert it's it's an image of Ray
it's most of its practical stuff that's
in that first teaser cuz they didn't
have to worry about the effects not
being done or looking off and
unfortunately as is so often the case
with Hollywood other studios saw the
insane level of anticipation that that
teaser and that marketing campaign your
long marketing build-up created for Star
Wars The Force awakens and they went
okay how do we replicate that and it's
not an inherently bad thing in movies or
anything else to look at something
that's successful in triangle well what
lessons can we learn from that the
problem is is that studio executives
marketing executives they that whole
upper echelon of Hollywood they want
quantifiable stuff and they also don't
like to hear that something that worked
for another studio won't work for them
so what that means is when something
like this hits they go okay break the
sound in there to its component parts
first teaser a year out and then keep
building the anticipation over the next
year equals big bucks not taking into
account the sort of unique state that
Star Wars as franchise was in that
allowed that to work and I think the
biggest hit
that was taken by other people trying to
emulate that was honestly the DCE you
our world of DC I suppose were supposed
to call it now this can't happen even in
a shorter marketing cycle but I feel it
was much more prevalent in longer
marketing cycles which is that we got a
lot more spoilers dropped in trailers
not necessarily first trailers but by
the second third fourth in some case
trailers for these things they want to
have something new in each trailer and
it wasn't too long before they were
dropping stuff that really should have
been surprises in the film Wonder
Woman's appearance in Batman V Superman
should not have been in the marketing or
you know even for a movie that wasn't
very good Wolverines cameo in x-men
apocalypse should not have been in the
marketing but when it's going for so
long they worry about it about the
marketing campaign losing steam as you
get closer to release so they're like we
have to be sure there's a new WoW moment
in the new trailer what else can we put
in there you end up with stuff getting
spoiled and then in addition to that
bringing it back to DC specifically
again you have things like the trailer
for the the first trailer for Justice
League dropping I don't think they'd
even finished filming the movie and they
were dropping a trailer and the thing is
any film is going to be changed and
altered and developed over the course of
its being made as a general rule of
thumb unless you're dealing with like a
writer director auteur on a fairly small
budget where they have really tight
control the movie that you have on paper
ie the script is not exactly the same
movie that you shoot which is not
exactly the same movie that you find in
the edit which is not exactly the same
movie that you finally released
to theaters after it's been revised
based off notes it is an evolving
process and when you put stuff that far
out you don't know what's gonna change
you don't know what you're gonna use you
don't know what what could be completely
altered and actually even the franchise
that got that start of this and did it
successfully Star Wars I think that's
part of the reason of what happened with
rogue one rogue one became infamous for
how many of the shots in especially the
first trailer were not in the finished
film and I think a big part of that
issue was how far out from released that
first trailer dropped because those
shots were very cool shots and I don't
think there's anything inherently wrong
with what gareth edwards said he did and
how he ended up with those shots which
was in the process of you know setting
up for other things
realizing ooh that's just a really cool
shot I'm not sure we'll use it but get
it get it maybe we will and then a lot
of them he ended up not using and that I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that but it becomes a problem when a
marketing team starts combing through
footage and comes across what is emitted
ly really cool shots and going that
should be in a trailer and you're not
far enough along in the the
post-production phase of it to know that
oh wait you shouldn't use that it's not
gonna be in the film you're too early so
when you're when you're making marketing
material that early everything's on the
table everything that that looks
finished is on the table and viable for
use in marketing so you end up with
stuff that does not turn up well or
another thing that happens with sahn
again with something like justice legal
though this was also compounded by the
timing for when they were shooting they
really didn't give enough time from when
Batman V Superman wrapped to be able to
make any adjustments based off their
reaction to that film it just assumed
that that would be a university love
film and it wasn't I mean some people
like it that's awesome but it was really
divisive and it didn't get the reception
that the studio was hoping it was hoping
for certainly so in the Mark
and having marketing material come out
that early also can also compounded that
issue to a certain degree because you
start putting on marketing material that
far out and if you get a negative
reaction from the fans it's far enough
out from the release that executives
feel that there's time to quote-unquote
fix it because if you drop a first
trailer for something and the response
from the people who are supposed to love
it is meant or that worries us or what
have you and you're still a year out
from production there's somebody at some
level who's gonna look at it and panic
and go oh my god this isn't gonna work
what can we change what and I think
that's a big part of like reshoots get a
lot of press these days in terms of the
size and scope of the reshoots and
reshoots and first of all let's be clear
are part of the typical filmmaking
process every film does reshoots
but reshoots do seem to be more
extensive these days and again I think
part of that is this desire to change
air or fix a film later on much later in
its development than normally would have
been typical and this desire to to fix
things and again I think starting to get
feedback that far up for release is part
of what has fed that mentality that has
resulted in these things that have you
know and I said I already said your
films change from the start to the
finish of the process but we were
getting things that are changing way
more than I think you would have
normally expected to see for things with
this kind of backing from the studio
with these kinds of budgets with this
kind of you know needs to be successful
nature to them because you you look at
something like justice league and you
had the early trailers where everything
was gray and everything was dark and
people who didn't like Batman be so
boring were like great it's all gonna be
gray and dark and gritty again then you
got a later trailer that was literally
lightened up they just did felt like
they just turned up the brightness
filter on the whole film
and it looks reactionary I mean it
probably was reactionary but it's a bad
look regardless because even if it was
always the plan for that sky and the
climax of Justice League to be red
instead of the gray we initially saw in
the trailer it still makes it look like
you're you're initially trying to sell
us on unfinished stuff because it's
changed drastically even within the
marketing materials say nothing about
when we get the final thing and I don't
think there's actually that much benefit
to a year-long active marketing cycle I
mean you know obviously these movies get
announced several years out you know
Kassie announcement so there's that
stuff but they might as well announce
that because you can't keep it secret
anymore there's there's really no way
between leaks and people sneaky on two
sets within literally these days
everyone has a camera in their pocket
you can't keep this stuff secret so you
announce that stuff as you go and but
then the proper marketing push I really
a full year doesn't really give you much
benefits again Star Wars The Force
awakens got away with it but I think
that is in a large part because it was
Star Wars and it had been so long since
the previous Star Wars that had been a
decade and I think that franchise was
just in a unique position at the time
they chose to do it and I don't think
really any other film has really reaped
much benefit from stretching out its
marketing cycle that far out because
eventually if you just if you do it
wrong what can happen is by the time the
thing comes out you're like oh man that
hadn't come out yet feel like I've been
hearing about it forever and it actually
lowers you whereas if you condense it
down again six months can still seem
like a while but if you condense down
that cycle it becomes a bit more oh that
thing and then when you get a second
trailer at I don't know around for three
months you go oh right that's coming out
and then you get your final trailer you
know a couple weeks out for mobile
easing you're like yeah mark my calendar
and
that is a pace that makes sense in terms
of the regularity with which you would
remind your audience that it's on its
way and you would get them excited for
it I don't see what what adding more
time to that because you're stuck doing
one of two things either you have bigger
gaps between each trailer basically
allowing people to forget more or less
since the first one came out unless you
truly blew their socks away and then you
know you might as well have started at
the six-month mark anyway because
whatever steam you built up with that
first one's gone or you have to release
more trailer material then we're back at
what I said that before you end up
revealing too dang much so I I just I'm
really glad I'm really relieved that the
marketing cycle seems to have shrunk
back down to what I think is a
manageable size and I just really
appreciate that I think um I can thank
Marvel for leading the way to a certain
extent and again this isn't like Marvel
does everything right Marvel is a very
practical reason to have a shorter a
marketing cycle which is that they
generally don't start doing much of a
push on their new movies until the
previous one is already out there are
exceptions here and there but Marvel
kind of makes a point about stepping on
its own toes so you know by the when we
got our first Infinity Ward trailer
I cannot remember now if it was after
black panther it might have been right
before Black Panther came out but it was
like pretty quick before it wasn't
overlapping with the primary poster for
the black panther marketing and so again
and same with with Captain Marvel you
know not only did infinity war come out
they've actually waited long enough that
you know is it out on home video yet it
might be now I should have checked that
but you know basically where that's run
its whole cycle and ant-man the wasp
kind of came and that was a palate
cleanser in a lot of ways and now you
know we get a breather and then all
right Captain Marvel and it's not
stepping on the toes of the stuff that's
already out because that's one of those
things that could possibly contribute to
just a feeling of this is too much you
know overwhelm and fatigued with the
genre when you
like you can't escape it like oh my god
there's like 50 things coming out
whereas what Marvel seems to be doing
which is pacing it out be like okay look
here's this film now it's out here's the
trailer for the next one or maybe like
slightly before it's out but like I said
not a ton of overlap and again because
Marvel films are really successful love
them or hate them they are very
financially successful and Hollywood
loves to imitate success so with Marvel
sort of bringing us back to the
six-month marketing cycle again I am
hopeful that that will become the
standard again for blockbusters as
opposed to this year thing which gahhh
I just don't think it did anybody any
good so those are my thoughts on
marketing cycles
I know ideal what the heck I'm gonna
title this this video I don't know what
you could call it that would be
interesting at all probably no one will
watch this out whatever if you did watch
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it whole bunch of stuff that you
can do because there's buttons and
there's links they take you places and
they do things like go to my patreon
maybe but in any case take a look at
them if you want to and remember folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]